brexit is fiendishly complicated you've
got lots of data lots of disagreements
and perhaps most of all
lots of terminology so let's flick
through the dictionary
and you get a sense of why we are where
we are
let's recall first of all that while we
have brexited in other words the uk is
formally outside the eu
nothing has really changed in practice
because we're still in the transition
period
but that period comes to an end at the
end of this year at least that's the
current plan
which is why we need a free trade
agreement
that's what's been negotiated at the
moment actually surprising as this might
sound when it comes to trade in other
words
tariffs and quotas on goods we're
sending in and out of our borders
the vast majority of it has actually
been agreed there's still some minor
disagreements over fishing
rights but really the big sticking point
really is something
else this the level playing field what
does it mean
in practice well there are lots of rules
which can indirectly
affect trade so environmental standards
workers rights state aid
for companies for instance consider if
the uk left and cut its standards so aim
to become singapore on thames
its companies could get a competitive
advantage or imagine it wanted to
subsidise its steel companies it's all
about
keeping competition fair again actually
everyone agrees
on that in principle the real sticking
point is about how these rules
get enforced so you've got one option
which is that the uk
and the eu agree not to diminish any of
those rules
non-regression as it's called the uk
being previously a bit reluctant to
commit to that after all
would potentially rule out singapore on
thames but now seems
keener but what if say the eu wanted to
increase regulations well that is where
dynamic alignment comes in this
principle says that
in the future if the eu changed its
rules on all this stuff the uk
should follow suit it's worth saying
these kinds of demands do go
considerably further than you get in
other typical trade deals but the eu
argues that given the uk would have zero
tariffs and be right on its doorstep
the rules should be tougher perhaps the
biggest sticking point is about how
those rules
get enforced does it mean in practice
the eu is still writing uk law
that according to the uk side would be a
dilution of british
sovereignty and that's a red line for
them in other words much of the talks
really comes back to this can they find
a formulation which makes it clear that
the uk
ultimately has the final say or
is that totally incompatible with the
nature of the eu we are about
to find out